turning to the pandemic one million
coronavirus vaccine doses are on their
way to pharmacies
across the u.s part of a new federal
program to expand
access maria villarreal is in mobile
alabama maria how is this going to
change the vaccination vaccination
efforts there well good morning anthony
you know getting doses directly to
retailers should help expand the access
points in here in alabama
where they rank last per capita in
vaccinations now the first shipments
should be arriving at sam's clubs and
walmarts across the state right now
later today
but here's the deal they are only
getting 15 000 doses
and that's in a state that has more than
a million eligible people
that are struggling to find the shot
right now
irene kozad's daily quest for a
coronavirus vaccine starts early
of course when i get up first thing is
on the computer so the first thing you
do when you get up in the morning
is check the computer i may have my
coffee but i'm on the computer
checking and i don't know
how much more i can do cozad is
desperate for the vaccine she and her
husband mark
both have underlying conditions he has
congestive heart failure
and she spent 2019 fighting colon cancer
after surgery and 12 rounds of chemo she
beat it
then covet hit and it just i feel like
i've lost two years of my life
to things that were beyond my control
my husband and i over the years we were
able to travel
he said one time stick with me baby and
i'll show you the world
and he did and i really miss that the 70
year old's
vaccination options are limited she says
the nearest mass vaccination
site to the owa amusement park complex
is first come first served with people
sleeping in their cars
overnight can you do that i just
couldn't do it not with my husband and
and uh and your health and my health
yeah alabama ranks
last among all 50 states in vaccinations
per capita
most health department vaccination sites
are already booked through april
the federal government is trying to
expand access by directly shipping to
pharmacies like walmart
micah matthews is the market health and
wellness director of this walmart in
mobile
he says his store is already being
flooded with calls
there are hospital options here but with
covid
it's so much harder for the community to
get to the doctor
and we're in a perfect proximity to help
people that
maybe couldn't have made it to
one of the large clinics kozad lives
more than an hour away from that walmart
and for now none of the stores around
her are getting doses
how does that feel disheartening
it's almost like where i thought there
was hope and light at the end of the
tunnel
now i'm getting depressed about it are
you ready to give up
yes and no i mean i've been through the
cancer
so i'm a fighter
cozad tells me she is struggling to find
the vaccine and she's struggling to get
answers so we contacted the state's
health department
they tell us right now their biggest
issue is just getting the vaccine
here in alabama they can't have enough
they don't have enough doses right now
to actually put on those mass
vaccination sites seven days a week so
they're relying on community health
centers and also small pharmacies to get
out to a lot of people in the rural
areas but even those places book up in a
matter of minutes
once the appointments are made available
gail
we feel for ms kozak that's a daunting
picture you just painted thank you
mariah